Julianne exiting dancing with the stars
are you bummed um no not at all i think
you think she did 3 c's great seasons
and it's time for her to go i mean
entirety guy like i said i crewed her
out samford again no you know she's got
great things on the horizon and she's
doing good great things and it lands
come back and so you know I think four
judges feels a little redundant anyway
so I think it's the thing it's the right
thing to do would you ever shift your
role from the dance floor to the judges
see who knows I don't know I don't know
not anytime in the near future I think
I'd be weird you know to be it'd be too
soon so he's not following Julianne to
the judge's table but Derek could be
following in her live-action musical
footsteps we asked if he'd be interested
in a part in the upcoming live action
version of hairspray set to air in
December he played coy hairspray it's
coming in December we thought you'd be
perfect for it yeah for luck who knows
hey have they have they asked you have
you talked about I'd even heard of that
but now oh you know I